[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
89 q and a segment
all cued up all queued up here we go
and we got fairfax on screen as well
here's our buddy
still missing his friend okay um
we had a number of a number of questions
um about
about sam harris and i think we're only
going to address
one of them just because we could spend
a lot of time in the weeds here
someone suggests someone asks what is
going on
this latest podcast from yesterday
sounded scripted by big pharma
is there any way you can have a
discussion with him
yeah um i don't see it that way i think
basically there's one error that is
propagated throughout
and the one error is imagining that the
truth of the situation
is clear that the science the science
has led to a clear conclusion and that
anybody who is not on board with that
conclusion is therefore making an error
and it's basically
a treasure hunt to look for where the
error is um
i see sam as a person
of extreme integrity i do not see him
as likely to be corrupted by anything
mundane i do think he has blind spots as
we all do
but no i don't think that's what's going
on i think
i think he was not familiar enough with
our
position to evaluate it and
he leapt too quickly but anyway i we are
open
to discussion with sam however he would
like to do that
so that we can get to the bottom of the
truth of that and if
if there are things that we don't see we
are of course eager to find out what
they are
at the moment it doesn't look like
that's the way it will head but um but
we are open to it
yeah okay so we're gonna do some some
covety questions and then
um and then move into sleep questions um
the site isn't quite working like i
thought it was going to so i have to now
find what i thought was going to be next
here we go
do you have a sense of how many if any
who are on the recommended prophylactic
dose of hypermectin of 0.2
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
per week have gotten sick with covid
man do i wish i knew the answer to this
yes i have no idea and i don't know that
the
the data are being collected in part at
least in this country because
um it's not being prescribed and so many
people who are on it are not on it
officially i agree that uh
it's ridiculous there are lots of
obstacles to that data emerging what i
have not seen and i do pay attention to
places where anecdotes would accrue i
have not seen anecdotes to this effect
yeah um so anyway what i'm i'm hopeful
that it is highly effective if you do it
right yeah um
but obviously we would want a bigger
data set yeah we want it systematically
uh collected and i have you know i've
this this is anecdotal but
um i've heard from a couple of people
who i respect
um who are vaccinated against covet and
who are um very pro-vaccinated and are
concerned
about those of us who are not um one of
them
similar stories in both cases but one in
particular said oh you know i've been
seeing these
this person is a medical professional
i've been seeing these doc
uh this this doctor posting on facebook
you know the sort of the glassy lung
the stuff glass opacities and it wasn't
exactly he actually showed me the
pictures and he's like it doesn't really
look like the grand glass opacities but
it's it's it's similar
and he said you know the stocks are just
posting all this stuff and it's all
unvaccinated people
and um i'm just really concerned uh and
unvaccinated people unvaccinated people
um and
i asked this this friend um this
acquaintance of ours
um do you know you know
is this person only saying these are
unvaccinated people
or are they giving any more resolution
on that for instance
are any of these people on ivermectin
and this is someone who like i said
is you know was hesitant at first
because they were brand new once there
were a couple of months of data out
got himself vaccinated um all the staff
he works with the vaccinated
is concerned for those of us who are not
um but said oh
you know that's that's a really good
question um you know all the evidence i
this person
said have seen suggests um that it
probably would be protective but i don't
know the answer to that
and so um there is a kind of a
fear-mongering and
sometimes it is unintentional that is
happening and you know i
we really want to know i really would
like to know what the evidence is
you're saying it is likely that ivor
martin would be
protective is that what you're saying i
i think it probably would be given that
we
have all this evidence that it is
effective in prophylaxis and effective
in treatment
but i don't but but but when you say
that you're saying
that you sounds likely logically
speaking
that it would be protective if given as
a treatment rather than a prophylactic
i mean it could be either these this is
this is a doctor who's having patients
coming in
to his this is not the person i know so
doctor who's coming patient's coming
into his hospital and reporting
look at what is look at what i'm seeing
and all these unvaccinated patients who
have coveted
now if and so you know my my question to
my friend was
were those people were any of those
people on ivermectin now that question
would apply either were they on it
prophylactically or were they
were they given it as part of a
treatment and well i would say
we can we can put a little color on this
because um
the kervaya study seems to indicate
that it prevents contraction and so
right like
we know we know have all of this
evidence and just in this particular
case
we don't have the data we don't have the
data on these particular things and this
is the sort of thing that is being
produced and distributed out there oh
look it's the unvaccinated people who
are getting sick like well
is unvaccinated the right category right
is unvaccinated and doesn't have natural
immunity because
um because they once had covet and it's
also not either on ivermectin
prophylactically and not being given it
for treatment is it that category we're
talking about because that's a much
smaller category
and also you have agency once you're
talking about that category because
there are things you can do
right right whereas vaccinated versus
and vaccinated
basically just says the only agency that
you have in the system
is you can choose to get one of these
these novel vaccines or you can choose
not to
and actually there is more choice than
that and we would be in a very different
landscape
we would be in a very different
landscape if there weren't good
prophylaxis out there and
and you know everybody's not the only
one we've talked about this before right
you know there's
the stuff in the protocols includes c
and d and zinc
um and carrageenan appears to be um have
potential you know
there are a lot of things with potential
and we would be having different
conversations if there was
nothing out there that appeared to have
prophylactic efficacy
right and we're also apparently not uh
official guidance has restricted the
collection of data
on those who contract coveted
post-vaccination if they're not above
some certain threshold of severity
right and i have begun to see i won't be
able to pull it up now but i have begun
to see some
mainstream push back against that like
hey wouldn't it be good to have data
wouldn't it be good to have
actually complete data what that was the
cdc's decision uh
minor cases of covid and those who've
been vaccinated those data we're not
going to collect anymore
great um okay
lovely heather and brett how are you
both we're so grateful for you
if someone with covet has been in our
home how long can it stay in the air and
on surfaces
we cannot find up-to-date information
anywhere
um i think we can do a pretty good job
of this for one thing
especially statistically speaking it's
very
likely that you are in the northern
hemisphere because that's where people
tend to be
um i mean it is
but anyway hey it's the northern
hemisphere it's summer
uh do what we do open all your windows
turn on whatever fans anything that
increases air flow you can
i mean basically yeah in that case like
everything like air filters
fans windows everything yeah everything
um you know and
go outside after you know but the person
is asking how long until their home is
safe
well here's the problem okay
we know that there's not very much
transmission uh
on surfaces does that mean it's
impossible no it can't be
impossible is not it's a standard beyond
which
you can go ahead and clean the surfaces
well i would certainly clean
you know the few surfaces that are
likely that they contacted and likely
that you will contact
and basically it's a diminishing returns
problem but probably if you did nothing
of that sort
the surfaces aren't where you would uh
contract the disease right it's in the
air
um it stays in the air
um you can reduce that effect by
allowing diffusion to
purify your air more quickly the more
your air
the more the more surface area your
building has
exposed to the world where it's
exchanging uh the
faster it will clear um the
you know i guess the thing is it's the
it's the model that we were developing
at the beginning of this whole thing
if somebody that turns out to be sick or
that you don't know and you think they
may
have been sick or you're just simply
unaware you know if they spend a bunch
of time in some
room then that room is much more
compromised than any other place and
you know airing it out makes sense
staying out of it so that you know
things that have hung in the air have
time to settle
all of these things will help um but
well maybe maybe that's that's just it i
i don't i think
at the very least it's going to be a
decay rate
issue and there comes a point at which
the
likely modes of transmission have
decayed
back so close to baseline that it would
be undetectable
yeah yeah we're not coming up with any
numbers but um
if you've got a lot of windows and you
open them all and there's any sort of
breeze at all
you're going to you're going to have a
complete exchange of air
in not too many hours should be yep
all right um
hey buddy uh this
is an interesting claim i don't know if
it's true uh the cdc.gov website has the
actual number of coveted cases that have
occurred in the u.s
at 114.6 million
important piece of information question
mark um
i mean i think it's if if true i just
don't know this is actually cases of
covid
cases of covid in the u.s that number
that's just way
no 114 million in the u.s 114 million
sorry
i misunderstood the number um no i think
that's actually in keeping
with the expectation yeah okay
um so important piece of information
um i mean i want to vet it but it's
certainly
well relevant yes i mean so i mean it's
relevant in that
um you know
if kovid confers natural immunity and
114 people
are contributing to herd immunity in
addition to the however many
100 plus million people who have
actually been vaccinated
um aren't don't we have herd immunity
well but we don't
right so there's something wrong with
that analysis because the thing is
spreading
what we don't know as far as i know i've
seen no data on it
um is to what extent the unvaccinated
and the post-covered overlap
right right they could be completely
independent it could be that people are
getting vaccinated
and they're having had covet is is a
non-factor in their decision-making or
it could be
that to the extent that people are
vaccine hesitant if you have had
covet and you've been told that you have
immunity that it causes you
to be less likely to be vaccinated in
which case yes the you would have a
composite number
that would be um you know and i i
wondered about this
uh during sam's podcast is we just
simply don't know
what fraction of the unvaccinated are
actually
immune in a formal sense
you know what a good accurate data
well but this isn't isn't this the most
amazing thing about this pandemic is how
extraordinary we
can't you know a we can generate
these utterly remarkable vaccines
lightning fast
we can't figure out how to collect
decent data on
who's been sick or
any i mean you it's just amazing that we
have not gotten reliable tests where
people can simply establish
that's a different thing but yes that
too tests testing
um data on you just how about instead of
person vaccinated or not um add
four additional parameters to the data
that you're taking and hey you have a
lot more things that you can begin to
explain
but you would imagine that we would have
excellent data on
um who comes down you know
of the various variants who is coming
down with what variance after what
measures
right right you would just simply want
that and we can't seem to get it
yeah i think um some of the data coming
out of israel seems to be better now
it's a much smaller population
they have you know much yeah it's much
more
it's been much more homogeneous with
regard to the response of the population
level for the various measures
yeah um but uh but yeah we're doing a
crappy job and you know and have been
since the beginning you know and it's it
was it was very easy
in the beginning um to to point to trump
and say
he's he's watching this completely but
it's just
continued to be botched it's like one
continuous botched job
yes nobody has debauched it yet no
debauching um
yeah uh no look at the beginning
you had trump but you also had the fact
that we were scrambling
right this is no longer something that
we can dismiss
as you know everybody's trying to get
their footing
um so anyway there's something
conspicuous
it's differently political it's
differently political but it's um
equally damaging to actual progress and
getting this thing done with
you and your progress i know sorry
no question just wanted to thank you i'm
day five with covid and i have ms
but doing great thanks to iver mekton
that you introduced me to
from greece wow good luck um good luck
that's uh that's rough i'm glad it's
working for you
indeed is there any evidence that people
on prophylactic
uh ivor mike den who have been exposed
to sars kovi 2 develop some immunity
this is one of these questions you would
really want to know yeah my guess is no
i would have to say my instinct is no
and the reason that it's no is that
what data we have so a you have
very good protection it appears
from symptoms and then we have some data
that says that the reason you are very
well protected from symptoms if you use
it prophylactically is that you don't
contract right
so the carbide study in particular
suggests that because it used a pcr test
to assess whether or not people were
positive or negative for covet after
um using ivermectin yeah so
what that suggests is that you don't
have the opportunity to generate
um immunity because you haven't had a
battle with
the pathogen on the other hand there is
always this lurking question
about whether or not our immune systems
actually have a kind of
ability to census stuff in the
environment right
and i haven't seen it compellingly
demonstrated but there's a question
about whether or not an encounter with
covet in which you didn't get
infected could still convey some
immunity but wouldn't that be amazing
it would be amazing and it wouldn't be
you know it's exactly the kind of it
wouldn't be totally
novel in the history of humans
interacting with it would make sense for
the immune system to figure out how to
get a you know to basically
self-vaccinate with information from
pathogens however
the papers right distinguish between the
two of them you showed two papers
those papers suggest mechanisms of the
acquisition of immunity and to the
extent that someone could potentially
get
immunity from an exposure that did not
cause an infection
it is liable to be much dimmer than the
immunity that people have gotten
from these infections right the
intensity of interaction between the
immune system
and um and the pathogen
in the case of an infection generates a
broad scale immunity so
i guess what i'm saying is at a
technical level it might be that
somebody who was
fully protected from contracting the
disease could still get some immunity
but i sure wouldn't count on it
in brett's how the magic trick is done
speech from three years ago
a lot has happened he declared that an
epidemic of
he declared an epidemic of cowardice and
claimed the solution was to quote
engineer a mechanism to cultivate
security for those who stand up
society is still crippled by the simple
problem of talented individuals avoiding
the cost of fighting goliath
since brett's proposal have either of
you seen any progress towards being able
to provide people with enough security
to be able to join our collective david
um nothing formal i do think that there
is
ever more recognition of the importance
of this point
so i've i've made that point now in
several other places and i've
been involved in and seen discussions of
it i think it
i think basically it's right and people
resonate with it because
um because it's clear that
the absence of security
makes it very difficult for most people
the absence of security is real for most
people and the absence of security
obviously have implications has
implications for people's willingness to
take a courageous stand
um and so anyway i guess we are waiting
for a formal mechanism
but i think informally um
many people have spotted that this is a
real hazard and therefore a real
opportunity
to um to upgrade our
our capacity to fight um
did you want to take this opportunity to
show that or should we why not we okay
um yeah we forgot to do that earlier we
forgot to do this um
someone in our audience
bought one of these goliath shirts and
took a picture of himself outside google
headquarters
and i think it's fabulous and we shall
call him elhanon
yeah i think this is just great yep yeah
really is
yeah all right
let's see regarding
regarding memory storage
thought and perhaps memory of sights
sounds and smells are stored separately
and
brain has the recipes to bring up those
ingredients to create the full memory
does this make sense evolutionarily
um i think the next thing is something
different okay so i think i understand
what's being proposed yes i would say it
you know to the extent that it is true
that we store these things separately
um the i mean the answer is yes it will
make sense
that we do so would it also make sense
to store them
collectively yes you could come up with
a different scheme for doing that
i don't think we have a proper
explanation on the table for why memory
utilizes these things in the way it does
and in fact it's something i'm
i'm hoping to deploy soon
there is a a hypothesis that i think
neatens up our understanding of how
these things interact
and i'm eager to get it on the table
cool
um well i will say
i've written about the association of
memory with
with smell in particular in that
memories of a mugging piece
um in which i explore among other things
the um long ago association of basically
the the telecephalon the
the front of the five parts of the
vertebrate brain
that in mammals turns into what is
basically
most of what you think of when you think
of our brain or cerebral or hemospheres
and that primitively that front most
part that most anterior part of the
brain is associated with smell
and so the fact that now it is being um
is being used for uh memory and
for thinking ahead you know for both
planning planning in both directions
and along in time and i think also some
mapping actually so it's sort of a time
space aggregator
it shouldn't surprise us then that there
will be sort of some prehistoric
glimmers
of smell bringing up memory in a way
that
some of the other senses i guess the
other senses don't tend to do
in quite the same way but that of course
could you know could be chalked up to
each of the senses is different it works
differently
[Music]
i think if i can allow me to sum up what
you're saying the ancient teleencephalon
has now become the show and
telling cephalon
show-and-tell encephalon yeah um i don't
want to have to do this to you but it's
it's spelled
i mean who cares yeah spelling was
invented so
the thing that i as you know as you know
is that at the point that you've got one
it's clear that you are not paying
attention to anything that happens
at all i could repeat everything yes but
i stopped
talking it's like great okay go on come
on tell me anything no
no you already did yeah that's my point
okay you already did and so i
stopped talking i mean i would show when
i was definitely
i was having a good time i could tell my
proto pun actually
matched what you were saying better and
better the more you went on i was i was
i was
i was pretty pleased i will point out
that fairfax is not impressed yeah he's
uh
he's nonplussed again yes yeah
okay uh regarding dreams and brains
requiring a lot of energy to maintain
why do we think that evolution is done
with our brains and that's the result
maybe this is a dead end evolution is
not done with our brains
no not at all it's not um
hello friend um let's put it this way i
don't think done with our brains is the
idea
the point though and a major theme of
our book
is that we are a special creature
by virtue of having a generalist
hardware platform
that is amenable not only to having its
software
swapped out but to bootstrapping new
software for
circumstances that our ancestors did not
know anything about
and so the real answer to the question
is it's not that
selection is or isn't done with our
brain it's that the return on investment
comes from two places one is
bootstrapping new
software and two is
division of cognitive labor right by
teaming up with other individuals who
have other areas of insight specialties
uh strengths we are capable
of out thinking the sum of our parts
by leaps and bounds and these two things
are connected
right we get together around the
campfire as we present it in the book
and what we do is we figure out how to
think about things we don't know how to
think about
and once we have figured it out it gets
driven into
a layer the cultural layer that is very
efficiently transmitted one generation
to the next
and this mechanism is so much better
at enhancing what we are capable of
understanding and capable of doing
than upgrading the wet wear of our
brains that you should expect to see
software upgraded over time and the wet
wear
not changed very much not because
selection has given up on it but because
it has concentrated somewhere else where
effectively there's no limit why
because even to the extent that your
skull has cognitive limits
your kin group does not
yes good i realized that i forgot
the discord question for this week
and it's a fun one
hold on i gotta pull it up and it comes
with a picture
if zebra's coats discourage flies why
haven't all horses made this adaptation
and why would zebras do this
specifically
and they link to an article in the
atlantic you can show my screen here
zach this is from 2019
i think the surprising reason zebras
have stripes
by putting black and white coats on
horses a new study shows the pattern
discourages biting flies from landing
and here we have a horse wearing a
stripy coat so
well so the question is
why haven't if if this benefit exists
why aren't all horses striped
um but um in my thing first
top of my top of my head is
um that in the environments in which
non-striped horses you know new world
horses exist
or i guess actually non-striped horses
exist everywhere but africa
everywhere that horses exist they're not
striped except in africa um
that you know they're they're not
easy to predate except when they're
young um but
that the stripiness is going to help
with camouflage in some other
environments and
very much not in other environments and
the flies are going to be a problem in
some environments and somewhat less of a
problem in other environments
and the various trade-offs therein are
going to render
a more camouflaged coat that might not
be stripy
a better choice in especially in an
environment that doesn't have quite so
many flies or if
even if the flies seem annoying if
they're not carrying so many diseases
yeah so a it could be
that the hazard of the fly so a
trade-off wise i would argue probably if
that code is
really about discouraging flies it comes
at a cost
right right um and so the point is why
would you bear that cost assuming that
there is a cost why would you bear it
one of the reasons you might is because
your flies are more dangerous so
i couldn't tell you whether ct flies
bite horses and sleeping sickness right
away but i can certainly come up with
lots of
examples of fly-borne illnesses right
and so it could be that it's the
flyborne illnesses rather than the flies
themselves um but i do think
it is interesting that it has created
a code based inequity
oh terrible okay right inequity yeah
yeah
ecwid no i got it yeah yeah you did i
just um inequity
inequity um yeah
okay right i mean that's all that's i
can't go much farther than that no no
you can't yeah
my brother and i have a few days for a
backpacking trip we can gain a day of
hiking if we lose a night of sleep and
drive from lax
to the sierras at 11 pm worth it or bad
idea
if you are willing to accept the
reduction in your overall health going
forward from the lack of sleep
um no i think this is actually how the
calculation works
um not sleeping is bad for you
there are reasons am i wrong that i'm
answering exactly the question they've
asked yeah but they but
this is this is asked presumably as
we're talking about sleep in the last
hour
right and so like they they know that
there are costs so they're asking for
an analysis that's not totally
yeah go on go on i mean this is how i
would do the calculation
that there are certain things worth
giving up you know you
will the effects on your health from a
single night of surrendered sleep be
measurable almost certainly not
but if you make these kinds of decisions
regularly then
you will have health effects yeah you
absolutely will pulling all-nighters
um in order to deal with a test the next
morning or a deadline at work and having
that be something that you do
once a month not good for you like
actually really not good for you and the
sleep deficit doesn't get fixed the next
time you get a full eight hours of sleep
like it takes a few days to
to deal with a sleep deficit and there
are lingering effects like all of this
is true
that said in this particular situation
in part because like they're
speaking our language like we we used to
backpack in the sierras you did
a lot more than i did as a kid but we
both we both did
um lax the sierras depending on where
you're going i mean you could be going a
lot of places but you know it's anywhere
from
five to seven hour drive um probably
five to like 11 hour drive depending on
where you're going but you know if
you're going to the eastern sierras
um something in there there's two of you
um it's pretty straight shot um i don't
i haven't been in the 395
in a long time but it's uh you know you
could you could share
like you could each you know drive for a
few hours and let the other ones sleep
and then you're actually gonna get a
little bit of you know you're not gonna
get a full night's sleep but make that
first day of hiking
a relatively gentle one and you know
don't
you know as opposed to spending the
night you know
somewhere in it you know in a la is a
amazing world-class city but
being there as you prepared to go
backpacking having arrived at the
airport late at night
not interesting i would totally get to
the sierras as soon as possible
yeah me too and i like the sleep in the
car plan
i think that uh we used to i mean we did
a couple of cross-country trips
um when we were transporting cats as
well
when we were moving from santa cruz to
michigan and then from michigan to
to olympia where we just spelled each
other we just went straight through
except we did stop we did take a detour
on the way back to see um mount rushmore
yes i remember showing we showed cats
yeah rushmore
which they did not appreciate as much as
i was anticipating they would oh strange
yes very strange maybe less patriotic
than i had thought
yeah these are long since gone cats yeah
you know they had seemed
patriotic they did they you know on
casual look they appeared very patriotic
but
at mount rushmore i certainly not
impressed no
okay um but yeah i would i would do the
extra backpacking i would pay the
physiological cost
and just don't make a habit of it right
thank you for being here and taking the
time if empathy is rare in humans could
gratitude help
level the field and create a better
world
if empathy is rare i don't think we need
the caveat i don't think we need
to figure out if empathy is rare in
humans i don't think it is i think it's
facultative
and i think a lot of our environments
now especially the online environment
make it um
more difficult but um certainly
increasing gratitude
being grateful being explicitly grateful
to people to whom you feel like you
you owe gratitude um
absolutely i i do think actually prompts
an empathic response in other people
yeah i mean we there's certainly no
shortage of
social science data suggesting that
various emotional states
are contagious wouldn't shock me if
gratitude
slotted in there very easily yeah but i
would say even just beyond gratitude to
people
the thing that i think is very easy to
lose sight of
is just how lucky you are
to exist and you know i can't say that
to everybody people certainly have
bad circumstances that i would have a
hard time arguing
are deserving of gratitude but for most
of us
you know we live free of fear from
predators
free of fear from dying of a
bacterial infection which might have
threatened our very recent ancestors
you know starvation is for most of us a
very remote
threat and there's an awful lot of room
to think about and do what you
choose to do and to find good people and
spend time with them so
anyway there's a lot of room to be just
simply grateful for what's available to
us and the problem is that we so quickly
equilibrate
to what we have available to us that we
take it for granted and don't
think about how lucky we are and it's an
easy thing to get over if you just start
you know teleport yourself randomly back
into history into some random person's
position and then compare what you've
got to what they've got and what you
fear to what they fear
and you'll see you're probably in a
pretty good position to to be more
grateful than you
than you would do ordinarily
in honor of your a cat related question
why do cats chatter pent up energy
mimicking prey do wildcats chat or do
other predators chatter
that's not a good question it's such a
good question and of course we've
thought about it this guy
has a weird habit of um he
reliably chatters when somebody opens
the silverware drawer
and i guess the crazy lights in our
kitchen caused the silverware to
reliably cast
weird shadows on the ceiling or little
reflections and he will chatter at it in
that way that cat owners know that their
cats will chatter at birds out the
window or whatever but he'll do it like
seven eight nine times in a row
yeah he's it's it's i at some point it's
going to go away but
um it's amazing how how reliable he's
been
i had you know i've heard people argue
that it's somehow
trying to call prey items i don't really
believe
that my guess is it has something to do
with um sort of cryptically maybe
alerting the parent
cat to the presence of something that
might be hunted or something like that
oh that's interesting so
just as um in the wild adult cats
those species of cats that do per adult
cats don't purr
that the chattering may be a kind of a
pedomorphic
thing where it's a it's a continued
kittenhood
vocalization yeah um and in fact
you know i don't think this is a hundred
percent true but it is certainly
very close to a hundred percent true
that cats don't typically meow at each
other either
right they'll have hiss and stuff but um
but they typically the all the
vocalizations and for those of you who
don't own cats cats have a terrific
range of vocalizations surprising um
but they typically do it to us and so
it's very easy not to know that because
you're always there kissing and growling
is the exception but meowing and purring
no that's not
yeah that's not directed at each other
right and so it's quite possible that
the chattering is another one of these
things
and it'll be interesting well it's not a
dress it's not um
the prediction would be that mothers and
kittens mother cat and
kitten cats do engage focus that way
right and we know that the purring
certainly goes from kittens to moms
right i don't know about the meowing the
i would be interested to know
i'm not quite ready to predict that they
don't chatter
to themselves if no one is home because
it may be that they're not
that they sort of consider you home and
so that they they chatter irrespective
but
yeah um but i do wonder if it would be
reduced
if you weren't there and that would
indicate that it was about communicating
something to you rather than
to the animals they're chattering at
yeah
how much effort have you put into
investigating conspiracy theories
for instance 911 jfk epstein et cetera
and which do you find most compelling
um
that's a tough question i mean look
um
[Music]
collusion happens
the question of conspiracy theories is
so fraught
that it's just uh
it's an um even the ones that we know
happened one gets dismissed for
believing in them so you know it's a
losing landscape to try to navigate at
all so
yeah i don't believe in any of them i
don't think conspiracies have ever
happened
and um yeah no we
conspiracy happens and it can't be your
first um
hypothesis all else being equal but uh
but the
idea that it's impossible is uh just as
naive as the idea that it is ubiquitous
um you know it's neither the only
explanation for everything
nor never an explanation for anything
nor a pure category
because as we've definitely not a big
category lots of emergence
there's lots of collusion these things
often inhabit the same landscape and
very much so yeah um why don't we know
which vaccine has the most breakthrough
cases in israel it's over 60 vaccinated
that have breakthrough infections
it's over 60 percent vaccinate that
right i don't know if that
framing means 60 of the breakthrough
infections are vaccinated or 60 of the
vaccinate have breakthrough infections
that can't be that can't be true that
can't be but we'd know that but the
former doesn't make any sense
right um so i i don't know
it might i mean in israel with something
close to 90 or so of people who are
vaccinated
if percent of the breakthrough
infections are
right now what does that mean right
through infections are inherently
yeah people okay so um yeah
so i i don't know what it means um i
will say there is the obvious caution
that in a 100 percent vaccinated
population
all cases would be breakthrough cases
which doesn't necessarily mean the
vaccines are less
effective than people this is actually
this is a point that sam made in the
podcast
that he did it's a point that we've made
yeah of course it is so
uh yeah yeah but why don't we know why
don't we know
where are the data um you know wha
why don't we have good data why don't we
have access to good data speaking of
collusion one reason we don't have good
data is that
good data threatens us to upend a good
narrative
yeah all right um
i'm looking for more questions sorry
um does the current rate of positive
covered cases amongst the vaccinated
worry you yet if not what would you look
to see if immune escape is occurring
of course you know i'll say the same
thing i said earlier
the
the fact of breakthrough cases
the fact of breakthrough cases cannot
help but
create a de facto gain of function
experiment and
because of that this is an obvious worry
unfortunately what one would
look for is at least loosely
uh similar to what we are seeing which
is a proliferation of variance
as vaccination rates go up
and i think the other thing i mean
there's a lot there's lots of different
kinds of evidence
for example you could have vaccination
in multiple parts of the world
that would result in convergence in the
sequence of variants
that are separate and i believe we are
seeing this
so what that says is if you apply the
same vaccine
in multiple places the escape variants
will
come to resemble each other because the
way you escape from the immunity created
by the vaccines is similar
so anyway what i would love
is for civilization to get serious about
answering this question
and to collect information on what these
variants
are where they are first seen
what they are successful against and
uh to do the analysis properly i don't
think it's even all that hard i just
think
there's a obviously a battle with
a huge number of billions billion
billion dollars at stake
that is resulting in the analysis being
poorly done
what are your views on the rare earth
hypothesis
also you should join forces with dr
chris martinson of peak prosperity
kindred spirit
um i don't know what the rare earth
hypothesis is
yeah do you i don't okay
uh we don't have views on the rare earth
hypothesis
that a earth-like habitat i have no idea
i'm not i'm
you can say whatever you're going to say
but i have no idea um chris martinson
yep yeah fond of chris martinson
he uh he seems like a good egg uh i like
his approach
stay tuned
oh wait we did that one
can you explain the evidence for your
effective volume model and do you think
there's any safe distance in a house
with closed windows
thank you for your insights you know i
put together a bunch of the
um evidence um
i think the the coining of the term
effective volume was was brett's but
i wrote a piece um that hopefully now is
going to be out
in a few weeks um but a while ago
um looking at the evidence for
um the value of
open air and fret and moving air um in
reducing
uh infections and bad outcomes in
hospitals um so
i you know i'm not going to walk us
through it right now but that that'll be
out
soonish and um do you think there's any
safe distance in a house with closed
windows when i get
it just depends so much on how much
viral load a person has and
yeah but the model says that that's not
a
number right but what it says is
that okay let's take the original
variant with the original variant
it took a period of time for a healthy
person to cross the threshold where they
got
sick when confronted with an unhealthy
person
so as time goes to zero risk
goes to zero right so a
very sick person presumably takes less
time to saturate the air
and therefore takes less time for you to
cross the threshold
but it's i think the point is it's not a
distance
if a person has been in a room a small
room with no air circulation exhaling
that room is effectively saturated
then the only parameter that matters is
how long you spend
in the room breathing that air to the
extent
that you open a window in that room it
causes the saturation of the air to drop
and it increases the amount of time it
would take in that room for you to cross
that threshold
if you have sufficiently great air flow
then it may be that the equilibrium
level in the room is so low that you
you know could spend a very long period
of time in that room without contracting
it
so it's going to be a model with
multiple different
um parameters you know it's like well
how how much does this car
you know burn in gasoline per minute
right is it going uphill
are there four people in it you know is
there anything in the trunk or right
the surface that's driving even is one
of the cylinders not firing
right yeah so all those things combined
suggest there's not going to be a number
that is a safe distance
but that there is a model that you can
use to
basically figure out what the danger of
a given scenario is if
a person you are with in that room is
sick
but again now we have the question of
variance right and it may be
that those numbers change radically
depending upon what variant a person is
sick with or maybe that they don't
change very much yep but yep
at least we don't know yeah okay so
i'm gonna read the next one off my phone
because there is there are a lot of
glitches two weeks ago
and some people asked questions that we
never saw here's one
are people more likely to hold on to a
paradigm when in a state of fear
i've been trying to explain to myself
why so many people are willing to ignore
evidence and make flimsy arguments these
days
my best guess is the fear of a paradigm
breakdown maybe the cause of their
irrationality
what are your thoughts i don't think
it's quite that simple
but i think there's something to this i
mean surely there should be
a um
a kind of evidence that could accumulate
that would cause you to abandon a
paradigm very quickly
right and probably we see that right
like in a relationship
maybe if a certain kind of evidence
accumulates that the person you're
dealing with isn't who you thought they
were not behaving the way you
thought they were it might be that you
start to see that evidence everywhere
right you could over apply some new
paradigm
but in the case i think we have a kind
of a perfect storm in this case where
people
yeah i mean in fact we see it in well
that's what sorry but
i mean that's what paranoia is right
like that you know you so you you come
just to use your relationship example
you come out of a relationship that was
abusive in some way or psycho with
abusive in which in which the other
person cheated
and you're more likely to see evidence
of cheating or suspect people of
cheating the next relationship you're in
i think so there's you know you you
you have um it's it's a kind of
confirmation bias but not in the
usually um usually discussed context
yep i think uh i think that's true
i think our current scenario
unfortunately has people retreating
into things that feel comfortable and it
is augmented by the fact that
if you are surrounded by people saying
the same thing
it feels like well okay we've got to be
right yeah
and so you know well that's precisely
why you know like this
the the better skeptics project i really
think is is true like we
all of us could use you know people
who see value in what they are doing
who's whose goal it is to figure out how
they can up their game
right like and and you know find find
what what they've said or what they
think that isn't
isn't quite right you know and you know
the people who
don't want such things to happen if the
effort is is good faith and honorable
and well designed
are are those who probably have
something to hide or
not doing what they claim to be doing
well
what the idw was
succeeded in this right in other words
because it compiled people who were not
aligned in their fundamental beliefs but
seemed to be aligned in the objective of
figuring out what was true
it was like a safe context in which
to to have ideas
battle and so resurrecting a space
where that safety where you know you can
rely on
somebody else within whatever group it
is
to be honorable in the way that they
challenge you and that sort of thing
provides that kind of benefit
unfortunately
let's take the vax anti-vaxx false
dichotomy
yeah right there are people who are
anti-vex that is to say
across the board just across the board
they don't trust vaccines for whatever
reason
and there are people who i think equally
absurdly
feel like hey if it's a vaccine it's
safe
right wouldn't have gotten through
testing well no
that's not likely to be true in an
environment with regulatory capture
and then there are people who are stuck
in some version of the bind that you and
i are in
or we want to trust vaccines and frankly
we want to have regulatory agencies
that allow you to tune out so you don't
have to be your own
protector right so you don't have to
evaluate it now if it got through the
fda it's safe
right right it's at least safe enough
for me not to have to to think that i'm
going to out-think the fda
but if the fda is captured it's actually
not that hard to out-think the fda
right it turns out you can do a lot
better than they do because actually
they've started with a conclusion
so point being we now see
lots of people applying the epithet
anti-vaxx
to people who it wouldn't have applied
to
three years ago because the point was it
was a
you know an unyielding position it was a
position against
vaccines rather than a position in some
intermediate space and so
well um that is certainly true for some
you know we've
we've met anti-vaxxers actual
antibacters um
but that word that epithet has been
applied to a lot of people
who do not have before before the
current
moment before a year ago um
that term has been applied and you know
used to render people
untenable in polite conversation against
very many people who actually have
nuanced careful scientific compassionate
humane positions
agreed
when did you guys stop i was like
beating our wives i guess when did you
guys stop sanitizing your groceries if
you did
we were thinking about stopping as of
monday now that we are both vaccinated
oh my goodness um i mean
here yeah we did yeah we were careful
about surfaces early on and then it
became pretty clear that surfaces were
not a major mode of transmission
yeah um for sars kobe 2.
and so we stopped and you know i mean
people people who've been watching these
live streams forever will remember i had
a
rubric about cotton gloves that i could
wear
when i was out and then ditch them put
them in the wash
as soon as i got home basically a
sacrificial layer
i wore surgical gloves at the market for
um a couple weeks
yeah a couple weeks um maybe a month or
so
back you know march march 2020 um
and i put i bought a bunch of copper
tape and i
put put copper tape on our outside um
door handles because it's it's
anti-viral um we never standardized our
groceries
um but we um you know we left packages
in the garage
for 24 hours if they came if they
weren't um if they
if they weren't gonna decay um and we
and we stopped putting you know bags of
groceries
you know for a while that you couldn't
use your own bags and so we wouldn't we
wouldn't bring bags and put them on the
counters we would only put them on the
floor and
yep and we were more diligent we almost
always
buy organic and so there's less of an
urgency from our perspective
of washing it because we're not washing
pesticide residues off of anything
of course some wise person at a farmer's
market says you should always wash
anything that grows lower than a bird
it flies one of my favorite vendors up
in the olympia
farmers market yeah yep but anyway
the point is it quickly became clear
that this thing doesn't transmit by
fomite very frequently and so we stopped
being vigilant the irony
is that all these other things still do
right
we've got all these other pathogens out
there and so
i i would love for us not to lose track
of the fact that we have actually had
an arbitrary impact on all sorts of
other pathogens because suddenly we're
all now talking pathogen which we should
have been from the beginning
yeah and the fact is flu ain't no joke
right and to the extent that we can stop
being cavalier i mean it has
never it has never ceased to amaze me
at how we don't think about
the horrible impact if you have the flu
and you're a little bit careless and you
get somebody sick and you cost them
you know however much health right
a solid week plus a bunch of later right
presumably they age faster they suffer
intensely for
some fraction of a week yeah right
that's a that's a huge disservice you
have done them and we don't put
nearly enough into thinking about how to
protect people from that
and you know suddenly we're now all
conscious about how germs do and don't
move around but we're too focused on the
one germ
right yes the one germ is pretty
freaking important there are plenty of
things that spread by foam rights
there are plenty of things and so like
you know public bathrooms like
at some point it's going to be
ridiculous you're going to feel
ridiculous being in a mask in a public
bathroom but there's
a lot of stuff you know public bathroom
we've talked about this before and
you know it's not pleasant but you know
public bathrooms don't have
toilet lids yeah and a lot of stuff
sprays into the air
and what an easy way to protect yourself
just a little bit by
masking up in a public bathroom it's
true yeah i'm actually watching
with some horror i mean on the one hand
it's sort of reassuring because it's
normalcy
but i'm watching the handshake return
there was a year there where
we didn't shake hands i didn't see
anyone well
there's that but to the extent that
there was a handshake it was like a
little funny every time you
bumped somebody by the elbow on the
other hand
are we so sure we want to resurrect the
handshake
i'm not yeah you know jake you know
we do need to be able to touch people
sure but frankly and i i guess
you know some things do transmit by foam
right yeah
for years long before kovid i tend to do
you know an elbow or at least the back
of the hand to press elevator buttons
um you know elevators these closed
spaces you just don't know who has done
what you know
put their fingers where and then touch
that thing and i was actually in a
this is months ago now but in some
medical something um
and i got an elevator and a couple of
people got in with me so it couldn't
have been that long ago because for a
while it was like only one person an
elevator at a time right
and it was a nurse and it turns out her
sister and i
and i asked them what floor and i
pressed it with my elbow
and they both just smiled big at me
under their masks i could tell
and the sister of the nurse said my
sister has been doing that since she was
little and she always knew she was going
to be a nurse
it's like yeah like that is going to
transmit some stuff if someone's sick
just touch that
and you touch that you might get sick as
it turns out you're not likely to get
sick with covet doing that
right possible but you're not right but
yeah how many other things are we
transmitting this way
and frankly i think handshakes are
suspect and not necessary
frankly i think a hug is less dangerous
than a handshake
that's a good news well i like i mean
look a handshake you know somebody has
touched a button right or they've gotten
sick and they've wiped their nose and
then you shake their hand and then you
wipe your eye and that's that
right and the point is that's a pretty
direct
route for pathogens to figure out yeah
um so anyway it's not that you know it's
not that i don't think the handshake was
doing something i know that it was i
mean evolutionarily speaking you know
it may be interchangeable with a bow but
it's doing something right and
you can't just you know chesterton's
handshake you can't just get rid of it
but we should pay much closer attention
we are living in
much greater density than we were and
you know there's a lot there's a big
cost to be paid for not being careful
about this stuff
indeed um
these questions do not necessarily come
in an order that i can
track so i see on brian's topic of
statins
so i don't know i didn't see brian's
question about statins nor do i know who
brian is but on brian's topic of statins
i feel permanent brain fog and loss of
20 iq points on simvastatin
i know very little about statins but i
but i have been
background sort of vaguely concerned
about them since i started hearing about
them there's something that feels
wrong i got nothing all i would say is
there's a welcome to complex systems
phenomenon where
you know and this fits very well with
what you read last week
about the victorians yeah and the idea
that there's a lot of the stuff where we
see a concentrated benefit of something
and we're not calculating that it must
come
with costs and therefore the idea that
you know we've gotten all of these
benefits
from medicine really needs to be
compared against
you know it needs to be calibrated and
you know trade-off
you know i think alexander when i
started doing my
trade-off stuff and i started looking at
pharmaceuticals
uh it was like you know this match is
exactly what he had thought that
all of these things have these costs and
that we really ought to
point a very skeptical eye at those who
are eager to prescribe stuff to us
and i also think um
you know every time we get sick and we
get better and we have a sense of like
oh
that was bad it's like no not only was
that bad but you just borrowed
from your future yeah and yep so anyway
that's not very specific on statins but
uh it wouldn't surprise me if you were
detecting something
uh real yeah
um we're asked a couple of times um
if which vaccine we would prefer
um and so i'm not sure this is a
question we want to
want to go down the road one thing we
have said is
um we're hopeful we're hoping for a
traditional vaccine
um we would be enthusiastic about um
a traditional vaccine um
early early on it seemed like the
uh the adenovirus vector dna vaccines
uh might be better because they have one
less piece of totally novel technology
involved in them but of course there's
some
um there's some safety signal um with j
j and astrazeneca that's not great
so um i i think i i think i would still
go there but i you know i'm really
hoping for um
there are a few there are a few of these
avenues with traditional vaccines that
seem to be
in development that um i would love i
would love to see come to market
uh i would love to see a traditional
vaccine on the other hand i would just
point out
a we're doing a crappy job of collecting
data on the current vaccines and there
is a way in which the current vaccines
are largely duplicates of each other
because they are all predicated on
exactly the same
underlying theory um
a traditional vaccine would be a welcome
development from my perspective but
at the point that it shows up we will
know nothing about its long-term impacts
and so this is going to be a constant
thing and totally
of course yeah um
do you believe that psychoactives are
perhaps essential for healthy human
experience
most cultures have them most
pre-industrial cultures have some form
of psychoactives
um as for whether or not every
individual needs to engage
i wouldn't i wouldn't go that far but um
in some cultures
all individuals are expected to engage
at some point and in some cultures it's
um it's only for you know particular
ceremonies like coming of age and then
um it's particular categories of people
like shamans
so you know given the plethora of ways
that different cultures have
basically brought brought psychoactive
substances and theogens
what have you into the human experience
i would say
they are valuable they are ubiquitous at
the cultural level but not necessarily
ubiquitous at the individual level
yeah i would agree with that i would
also say there are other routes there
yeah um so it you know yes it's cool
that you have
a mushroom that can trigger access in
this way
you know i will repeat what i always say
which is
it shouldn't be recreational which
doesn't mean you shouldn't have fun
but it means it's serious business and
you should treat it that way um
but there are other routes there as you
know
was in the section that you were reading
from the book there are natural
ways in which you end up there whether
you like it or not we just don't tend to
think of them in that way
and you know
the anthogens that you take are a hack
the endogenous experiences that work
this way are liable to be
regulated to your benefit on
average um and you know
somewhere in there yes yes the
mechanisms are probably necessary to
every single person
whether you need to do something special
to access them probably not
for many people indeed hey zach what
time are we at
all right let's do a couple more uh psa
for my state
references new public health england
research saying that delta is 40
more transmissible outdoors than alpha
what are your thoughts
i have not heard this i would love for
you to send that psa to
darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com so that we can take a look and
see if we can find
the evidence that they're basing that on
that's
something we've been you know praying
against and
predicting might happen since the
beginning of this
and i really hope it's not true i would
i would say it even more strongly
okay we have warned that it might happen
we have cautioned that the outdoor
environment appears to be a loophole
in the transmission logic and that we
should act to protect it
so we have argued that even though
there's no evidence for transmission
outdoors or almost no evidence that
caution when you are close together
outdoors is warranted and so to the
extent
that we have a new variant that appears
not to abide by that same rule if that
is in fact what we have
um that's because we screwed up because
we didn't we didn't
treat this like an evolutionary
environment from the get-go yeah
um b h good luck with your new book any
book recommendations for
our age um you know a few
but i will say i'm gonna i'm gonna punt
slightly um and say that we've actually
got at the end of the book of ours
that's coming out
um for each chapter one or two or even
one case maybe three books that we
recommend
that explore that topic that we that we
respect a lot in fact
the one for the sleep chapter there's
only one for the sleep chapter and i
happen to have it here so
um this book why we sleep unlocking the
power of sleep and dreams by matthew
walker
oh wow yep okay you got me here
i can't even tell here we go um
why we sleep unlocking the power of
sleeping dreams it's good
um so that's the one that we recommend
um associated with the sleep chapter and
there are
several um for
across the whole book next question
is also really just a comment
so grateful to you for both taking covet
seriously and seeing the lies
i do also thank you
yeah um sometimes i have stayed up 24 to
36 hours then slept 12 to 16 hours i
felt great
is this bad you know it's
there are there are some people who are
just different with regard to sleep
right and i think we probably
have all known or known of people who
really
actually seem to function totally fine
on almost
no sleep and
i've never run into an analysis of why
such people should exist or what exactly
is going on
and there are a lot of people who think
they are those people and aren't and
their loved ones can attest to that and
they're
you know their their co-workers and um
and and professors and peers and all
this can attest to that um
but you know the idea that you might be
someone for whom
uh basically going in longer bouts in a
longer sleep wake cycle might
might work that's not so surprising that
there would be some people like that out
there
yeah and i would say a lot probably
you can deduce from how you did it right
yeah
if you loaded yourself up on coffee or
something else to stay awake
uh then probably you're borrowing from
something
on the other hand if this is a natural
cycle for you
maybe not yeah beware the light though
because light is uh it functions a lot
like
a stimulant and therefore can disrupt a
pattern
yeah oh i'm seeing brian's question now
which
we aren't going to answer but any chance
of briefly discussing statins and
touching on cholesterol
thank you so yeah we don't we don't know
much but we already did that a little
bit
um can ivermectin potentially cross the
blood-brain barrier
uh perhaps with lack of sleep and or
covid
um i think we know a little bit about
this yeah we'll say i would like
some leeway because didn't see your
question coming and didn't look it up
i think ivermectin minimally crosses
the blood-brain barrier in a healthy
person even
absent other uh minimally meaning most
of it doesn't but it's not completely
absent but it doesn't require that there
was a parasite that already weakened the
blood-brain barrier or like like covet
that already
that will increase the transmissibility
but you're saying that you think there
is some evidence
that can minimally cross the blood-brain
barrier or even absent any other
permutation i recall that low
concentrations were seen
beyond the blood-brain barrier okay and
covid
covid and spike protein alone seem to
shred the blood-brain barrier which
presumably opens the brain
to the central nervous system to many
things hey
um that would otherwise not cross and
this is one of my concerns about it
actually it's one of the things
that i thought eric topple got wrong in
sam harris's podcast
was that it's not inherently the spike
protein that ends up
in the brain that is so troubling it is
that if the spike protein is shredding
the blood-brain barrier then
one of the protections for the brain is
reduced
and in a modern environment where you're
exposed to who knows what
you know off-gassing of furniture or
whatever it is that ends up in your
blood
not having the blood-brain barrier
intact exposes you to hazards that we
can't even
calculate right you can't keep track of
all the things
that your brain is protected from but by
that barrier and to the extent that it
is shredded
um that you are at increased danger
now i do know i talked to dr corey about
this the blood-brain barrier does
self-repair
so that's good news to the extent you
can stop damaging a healthy person
yeah um so you know it's a temporary
problem not a permanent one which is
really good okay final question
oh actually the the previous one two
more could you comment on doctors david
martin and richard fleming
and what they have said they are calling
the virus the vaccine a bioweapon that
was man-made
they've got patents as proof at
flemingmethod.com so i don't actually
know
i haven't seen fleming at all i've seen
you know some of the stuff going around
that martin has talked about and there
has been
there's been some um careful
what looks like responsible pushback
against enough of the claims
in some of some of what he's making that
um well some of it may well be accurate
um it's
really not clear what the overall um
message should be yeah it gave me a uh i
did watch
um martin's video yeah but fleming too
yeah i don't know fleming
i'm wondering if fleming is the other so
it was an un
known format to me in which
martin is talking and then it gets
translated into german for an audience i
don't know
so anyway whatever it is um i had the
sense
that no doubt many of the things that
were being reported are true
in the sense that there are patents i
don't know what the implication of those
patents
are and it was not obvious to me from
that presentation
that they are what was being claimed
yeah so i guess and there have been at
least some
um some holes poked in some of the
some of the connections made right and
so the thing
it i don't know that there's
anything alarming
in these patents because for one thing
what i kept noticing and again and again
was that the claim was made there's a
patent it is very early
but then it wasn't clear what the patent
was on and what we do know
is that people were working on
coronaviruses and so
i don't know how many patents get filed
i don't know how close these matches are
and therefore i don't know that there's
any implication at all yeah it was hard
it's hard to calibrate a lot of the
claims absent knowing things like
background rate of patents back
like right and how close the sequence is
you know if you've got a sequence that
is identical and it's
you know patented long before it's
claimed to be discovered
okay that's obviously a red flag of
something
on the other hand that's material is not
presented in a way that i could at least
glean it yeah so i'm i'm concerned that
the implications of
that presentation are not what people
are claiming yeah
i agree um final question
becoming multiplanetary solves for many
extinction scenarios
doesn't this make elon musk the most
ethical human alive today
no i would not uh
i'm not that was a good consciously a
fan
of elon in part because he seems to be
doing his
own work and concluding that
investments need to be made in things
and then
you know he's got a bias toward action
that i think i
applaud i don't you know necessarily
trust his judgment on all of these
things and you know there's a question
if it is true that um
immunity from extinction is
greatly enhanced by being
multi-planetary
then would a
dweller of the village in
1433 who was experimenting on getting to
other planets have been the most ethical
person on earth
would they have been wasting their time
right
so my point is that the immunity that we
get from going other planets
we're just getting out of farm work
right they're slacking
yes right so my point is i'm not saying
that elon is
too early maybe he's not maybe he's at
exactly the right moment at which point
these
uh investments make sense or maybe he is
too early and the point is he's not that
much ahead of the guy in 1430 whatever
making the same point um
you know so you can't do the calculation
that way right because if it's true now
it was true in 1436
and that would not have made the person
obsessed with it in 1436.
but you don't you don't even totally
believe this right like i
i get your point and it's an important
one but um there are moments
before which uh there is any possibility
of movement on a certain thing
and then there is a sometimes vast
period of time during which
the prompt is the prompt the pump is
primed you know there's there's an
ability to
receive information you know with this
there's also the technological things so
it's not just
you know are is the populist ready to
hear darwin right
um but there's actually a you know do we
do we have
um enough syncretism to like bring
together all the things that we need and
are we advanced enough in various
technological fields no i
i absolutely do believe what i'm saying
but i might not be saying what you're
hearing because what i'm saying is what
i heard
is a logical syllogism
right is he give given given a and given
b
you know okay is he is he there is he
the most ethical person on the planet
today right
now my point is that's not not
inherently that's insufficient premise
right yeah it is insufficient to reach
that conclusion okay
um but you know again i'm cautiously a
fan
right to have somebody that wealthy and
powerful
also be imaginative and courageous
and
uncoordinated
you're wonderfully coordinated what i
mean is with others
right the independence of the
perspective
is refreshing um i know what you mean
you know what i mean
everyone generous will understand what
you mean oh that's
maybe not as big a group as we need
um yeah yeah but the ungenerous are not
necessarily the musk lovers
so right
right yeah right have we reached the end
i think we have okay
well um we're gonna we're gonna go
outside that's what we're gonna do
um please consider joining our patreons
tomorrow
at 11am pacific is our two hour private
q a for the month the questions have
already been asked but
um we'll be answering them having some
fun doing so and be
and we'll be interacting with the chat
as well and um
go to store.darkhorsepodcast.org to pick
up some goliath shirts and other stuff
email questions to darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com
to whatever channel you're watching this
on and then the odyssey or youtube
equivalent and also
the darkrooms podcast clips channels
on on both youtube and odyssey to help
us out
with various algorithms and consider
liking and sharing the video
and i'm sure i forgot something there
but
be good to those you love and eat good
food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]